we begin with this the news is not good
when the weather in some parts of the
country where thousands of people in the
southeast they are starting a cleanup
that will take weeks after this
country's deadliest tornado outbreak in
nearly six years dozens of tornadoes hit
Alabama Georgia Florida and South
Carolina on Sunday hundreds of homes and
businesses were leveled Lee County
Alabama is ground zero for the
devastation at least 23 people were
killed in Beauregard Alabama where the
County Sheriff says it looks like
someone took a giant knife and scraped
the ground CBS Evening News anchor Jeff
Glor has been reporting for Brewer got
from Beauregard Jeff good morning Nora
good morning the damage here is just
unreal we are outside the home of
trooper Robert Burroughs his home was
destroyed Burroughs this morning was
badly hurt he is in the ICU in the
hospital we just spoke with his wife she
is hopeful he will pull through today
but he is one of the many many affected
by this terrible storm the house
exploded and the force of the tornado
snatched both the kids away from me
Bobby kid described the moments a
tornado dragged his grandson
six-year-old Ageing Hernandez away from
his father they were unable to find AJ's
body for a while
he was able to find Jordan and they
started walking and looking for AJ
Hernandez's brother 10 year old Jordan
Griffin was taken to the hospital along
with his dad both are expected to be ok
the National Weather Service says an
ef-4 tornado was one of possibly two
tornadoes that ripped through Lee County
Alabama winds of up to 170 miles an hour
it is the deadliest tornado since the
2013 disaster in Moore Oklahoma early
estimate at least 24 miles long I
estimated the path width at point 87
miles or almost a mile wide rescue
workers have been searching the damage
using k9 units and drones to look for
many that are still missing at this
church in Opelika neighbors came
together to bring supplies to the needy
it's just really nice to
see the kingdom of God worked together
for the good of everybody in nearby
Smith station
Shannon Kelly broke down looking at what
was left of the home she lived in for 20
years I don't have a clue where to start
up like I don't even know
because of my house was 300 yards down
the road in Beauregard we met Joseph
Vernon he lost his home and his neighbor
and friend like my neighbor's house
right here and we find it and stuff down
there in their yard Joe told us his
family just finished rebuilding their
house after who was lost in a fire right
where we standing we had a house burned
we just got rebuilt reestablished and
you know this here's a look from above
this morning you get a better scope of
just how bad this damage is this tornado
knifed through 24 miles of this area the
search and recovery efforts continue
this morning complicated a bit right now
by the fact that a freeze warning
continues until later this morning John
back to you in New York Jeff thank you
so much what an extraordinary set of
pictures